we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p you can call it anytime you
want
here's a voicemail i received this
morning about the possible independent
presidential candidacy of starbucks
founder howard schultz take a listen to
this
hey david my question for you would be
what is your stance on rank-choice
voting because with all the ruckus and
stuff going on right now with howard
schultz I've really been thinking about
it a lot lately employers would really
solve a lot of problems so it's for how
Democrats is so worried about being
split
even though Gary Johnson got two percent
of the vote and she'll find out one
percent of which actually took more away
from Trump but anyways they're panicked
about that and then the progressives
don't like if the independents don't
have a chance so I think it's a good
idea but I'm really curious what your
thoughts is that goes beyond that great
thanks absolutely I've been talking
about this for years I've been an
advocate of ranked choice voting we've
had ranked choice experts on the show we
are going to talk actually on today's
bonus show about Howard Schultz and his
possible candidacy tomorrow I'm
interviewing Democratic presidential
candidate Andrew yang whose campaign I
really like and I'm interested in and he
opted even though he's a more
independent minded guy to run as a
Democrat and my suspicion is that it's
partly because he doesn't want to be a
spoiler or do anything that might help
Donald Trump get reelected so I'm in
favor of rank-choice voting I share the
concern around Howard Schultz I think he
will only help Donald Trump get
reelected and we will talk about that on
today's bonus show along with this is we
heard a lot of strange things from
Donald Trump after the recent California
wildfires we are now learning that PG&E
is filing for bankruptcy as the
California wildfire liabilities loom
large financially for them in California
we will also talk about the FBI has been
looking for a motive in that Las Vegas
mass shooting from last year a
it was last year no wait not 2017 either
no is the end of 2017 neither October
November end of time unbelievable
unbelievable the FBI has been looking
for a motive and has found none for that
Las Vegas shooting and I want to talk
about that and it relates to a lot of
other important issues with regard to
bad things that happen and conspiracy
theories and much more so it is one of
the best bonus shows I would argue of
the week today sign up at wwlp.com or as
a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show and we will talk about all
of those stories and more